takes courage to make money not money
that's why immigrants come to America
and make money
they came with nothing except what
courage you lost your courage when you
got in the middle class the great things
that have happened on this planet and
continue to happen or because people are
unreasonable
they literally abandon reason and logic
they defy the universe your parents were
looking for 40 grand it doesn't pay for
anything today so you need to change the
way you think need motivation what's the
dope then we believe nation what's up
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
on to the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and
chewing today's lessons from a man who
went from having a DD drug addiction and
almost dying growing up to becoming a
best-selling author top sales expert and
having over half a billion dollars in
real estate
he's Grant Cardone and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 5
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be courageous
how many heard the same avoid takes
money - that's not true it takes courage
to make money it takes courage to make
money not money that's why immigrants
come to America and make money
they came with nothing except what
courage you lost your courage when you
got in the middle class you trade your
courage I'm doing good you think you're
doing good - the brains Falls rule
number two my personal favorite be
unreasonable the thing that I do at my
company that is very unusual is that we
are completely unreasonable without
reason without we don't use yes I'm
logical okay yes I'm a sane person but
when it comes to achieving a target we
we do it with like we abandon reason and
logic we don't talk about yeah but we
never start yeah but or no we can't or
we couldn't because or it didn't happen
because any any time you're talking any
time you're making sense of why
something didn't work we don't have the
budget we can't do that because yeah but
we're different you are being reasonable
the great things that have happened on
this planet and continue to happen or
because people are unreasonable
they literally abandon reason and logic
they defy the universe now if you look
around if you're a logical person if
you're a person has to make sense of it
beforehand then spend some time looking
around the universe look at nature look
at all the things that are done everyday
that literally defy gravity the five
possibilities to five physics it's all
over the place if you need to be
reasonable now in my case I don't need
to be reasonable because there's enough
cases of super successful people doing
things that are amazing whether it was a
manufacturing a new product or whether
it was Steve Jobs coming back to Apple
and turning that Cup
around every day every look at the
Amazon look what Amazon is done okay now
you look at it you're like dude does a
no-brainer make it make all products
available online now it's a no-brainer
now it's like it's so logical look at
Velcro velcro is like god I should have
thought of that see but beforehand it
was completely out of reason that you
could stick things together because they
scratch one another you understand what
I'm saying so look this is what I want
you to try try this in your life it's
gonna be very difficult one of the most
difficult things I do is being
unreasonable because all the people I'm
surrounded by are trying to make sense
of why they can't do something
quit making sense of why you can't do
something and become unreasonable until
you do do something rule number three
show up what are you gonna do when you
wake up and you feel lost you feel less
than you feel you feel a sense of either
depression or despair and no direction
what I do is this I show up I show up
man
buddy might told me when I was hit
super low point in my life he said a man
show up even if your life's if your eyes
are bleeding and your life is low show
up anyway show up rule number four think
big
bigger is better how many of you agree
with this okay if you can live on nine
hundred grand
the only people that won't go to nine
million are the people that are selfish
unselfish people grow their businesses
selfish people don't okay if you're
taking notes if you're gonna walk away
with something today I'm talking to the
able people here give me the name of a
great company that has seven employees
I'm waiting
give me the name of a great company that
doesn't spend a load of money on
advertising who is this company
tell me give me one name one name of any
company that's great
this small CCC you you built a business
on a fantasy right like I'm gonna get a
stake for I'm gonna get a stay for him
I'm gonna get an all-state company imma
imma be an Allstate guy and I'm gonna
make nine hundred grand a year you're
selfish folks see see what I'm saying
about the selfish person makes what they
need the unselfish person says I'm gonna
make more than I need rule number five
work on yourself I've been lost most of
my life literally the first 45 years of
my life the first probably 51 years of
my life first 45 years for sure I was
completely lost and somewhere between 45
and 51 I started figuring out okay what
am i doing I started sort my life out I
started getting some started doing some
courses that really really made a
difference in my life I've always been
in a self-improvement my whole life and
but it wasn't until I was about 45 that
I really started discovering information
that could make me more confident me
more sure you know when I was 25 years
old was a young salesperson and I didn't
like sales and I and I got educated on
how to sell and I became very very good
at it I started to understand the
process the customer the objections the
rebuttal is how to follow up how to
handle the rejection and the
disappointment that discouraged how to
get over but that didn't help me become
more confident in me as a person as an
individual I was making money by the
time I was 31 I had a couple businesses
they were making money probably had you
know three four hundred thousand dollars
saved when I was thirty 31 years old
because I was trying to make a little
money right
by the time I'm 33 I got it probably a
million dollars in a bank I still didn't
feel good about myself I just nagging
nagging like sense of desperation and
satis depression uncertainty a lack of
confidence and when I started working on
me spiritually that's that's when that's
when at 45 46 47 years old that's when
everything changed for me like
everything all the expansion the
confidence getting out in the world
maybe a little better communicating than
I was doing I'm not perfect at it by any
means now and I started getting more
certainty about Who I am what I am where
I'm going and why I'm here like if you
don't figure those things out no amount
of money no amount of money in the world
will will fill you up note the private
planes won't the fancy cars
you have to know where you're going rule
number six build the team how do you do
this I started with one employee
his name was Craig Cardone I'm doing and
so I hired him right he passed the drug
test I believed in him and for 15 years
I was one guy and then one day I woke up
a guy actually I'm a mentor of mine said
look you can't scale with just yourself
you got to start building the business
here you're gonna have a real business
you need employees you need people you
need to be willing to hire people and
I'm like man man I'm scared they cost
money he's like not making sales 1 2 3
or these empty desk okay that's what's
costing you money staying small is
costing you money all this cost money
I have failures here I have
disappointments I have discouragements I
have people that work here for a little
while and I quit but you're not gonna
get big by yourself rule number seven
don't rest on your laurels if you asked
me to coach your business I'm not gonna
think about how to hold on to what you
did last year that's what most people
right now are thinking here in March in
January you were like there's gonna be a
great year by March you're like man I
just want to do what we did last year if
we just you're starting to make sense
you're becoming reasonable okay I'm
telling you that because this is what
your people do - okay your people the
people that you hire they make sense of
how to make 40 a grand a year and if you
have people in your company they're
trying to make sense out how to make 48
grand a year you got a company it's
gonna die toys-r-us filed bankruptcy
this week I Heart Radio the biggest
radio station in the world filed for
bankruptcy this week there's gonna be
massive disruption in the marketplace
why because these companies thought
about they kept they kept having
trophies about what they had rather than
what they could get who's got money
who's qualified to buy how can I get
their attention how can I tell them what
I want from them okay how fast can I get
to the marketplace fast speed is the new
big rule number 8 do more you can do
more
you can do more than you ever imagined I
was broke at 25 years old broke okay
every two years I get one of these cars
the people at rolls-royce like like I
wanna send you another one of those cars
okay how you want it how you want to
dress what color you want it that gets
crazy it's crazy the life I'm living
right now we did a we did a conference
it was ten thousand people in the room
and another ten thousand people in line
all of them paid to be there I remember
when I couldn't get two people to show
up at a party in high school because I
was so disliked you can do more than you
think you can is my message to you today
you will live longer than you think I
promise you okay you can do more than
you think you can rule number nine go on
the offense
your parents were looking for 40 grand
it doesn't pay for anything today so you
need to change the way you think how
many of you were taught when you ate
when mama brought you a meal she said
this she brought you the meal threw it
on the plate and said eat it all how
many were told that you know what she
was trying to tell you don't waste money
that's what she was trying to say what
she was really saying is I don't know
how to make more money she was really
saying there's a shortage of money eat
it all there's people in China starving
how many got that message every day how
many of you when you walked out of your
bedroom your mama said turn off those
lights what was she telling you I don't
know how to get new money that's what
she was telling you my dad died when I
was 10 my mom was left to bring up five
kids okay and those are the messages I
got every day the same message was this
contract get small back up protect
yourself I can't win anything like this
I cannot succeed for my family like this
I do not want my kids to see me like
this I want them I want my kids to see
me on attack right confidence in the
marketplace how do you get confidence
you read man you guys got to read okay
the app the average American reads less
than one book a year half those books
are romance novels
now I don't have my books with me today
but we I've written four books since
2009 for this new economy I wrote those
books for me I didn't write them for
other people I did not write him to get
known I wrote those books because I was
trying to figure out how do I get myself
out of this problem
and you'll number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is have
fun I've been putting this off as long
as I can this whole you know
this whole thing there's no burnout I'm
starting to wonder maybe there's some
burnout because I've been feeling tired
and he beat up a dragon I'm starting to
really question some of the stuff I've
been telling you guys for a long time
about the whole 10x everything go to the
next level freaking you could do more
it's about time it's been a long time
coming I've been doing a lot of
reflecting about it saying hey I need to
tell people I think I've been wrong with
this thing
I am a candle in the wind
you know you can burn out it's not worth
all the work
hold - next thing all you guys about to
10x rule and you're like I gotta go to
next man I don't know when the whole
TARDIS in the hair you know just keep
showing up and telling me I'm thinking
rethinking the whole deal and for those
of you gonna follow me for a long time
jumping on that bandwagon telling you
gotta shut it down okay
taking a break of social media taking a
break on all the interviews I'm taking a
break on all the podcast get off these
freaking 80 100 hour weeks grind for the
money sell them a plane get rid of the
car scaling down everything everything
you get rid of all my debt I'm just
going back to freaking old school take
it easy
fool them in fact I tell you what I'm
gonna do let me tell you what I'm gonna
do first of all I'm getting a new car
I'm ordering a damn thing today it's
gonna be if you if with your permission
it's gonna be white oh damn I can't open
it up it's gonna be white I'm gonna I'm
gonna have it white I'm gonna have a
white on white with red piping all over
the place red dashboards gonna blow up
it's so scream when I go up getting a
new plane imma get a new freakin i'ma go
from nine passengers they're like 13 or
14 it's gonna be sad oh now I've got an
awesome bonus clip from grant on how to
discipline yourself that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know
what did you learn from this video today
what was the single most important
lesson that you're going to take and
apply to your life to your business
leave it down in the comments below when
you write it down you're making a
commitment to improve and so write it
down feel the satisfaction and then go
make a change thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
how do you
how do you discipline how do you struck
monitoring what you're saying to
yourself I can't find the right girl I
can't find the right guy a marriage is
hard I'm broke I'm torn it's gonna be
hard if you don't change your mind you
gotta change the way you think and a way
to change the way you think first of all
the one way is to start discipline
yourself catch yourself every time you
say I don't have time say hey I create
time every time you say I know have
money I create money literally like
talking to yourself hey I am a
millionaire so if you're broke right now
quit say and I am broke and start saying
what you want where are you going it's
not complicated you want to get rich I
got rich you want to get rich you can
nothing and no one stop that you can do
that but the information in your hand
them ways your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that that people
need passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's supposed
to mean I don't ever give up I'd have to
be dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten most of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details